[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جامبول
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
نبدا من محيط ستادلو سيل حيث ينطلق الشوط
الثاني من مباراه الارجنتين والمكسيك كنا
منافسات كاس العالم قطر 2022 الشوط الاول
ذهب بالتعادل السلبي
والى هذه الصور من المدخل الرئيسي للعاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد والمغلق بحويات
نقل البضائع لمنع اتساع مسيره واحتجاجات
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
والى واشنطن بعد قرار من هيئه تنظيم
الاتصالات الامريكيه بحظر معدات وخدماته
50 شركات صينيه ابرزها هواوي لاعتبارات
تتعلق بالامن القومي بحسب نصر قرار
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
تحت قصف مدفعي تركيه استهدف مناطق سيطره
المسلحين الاكراد في شماليه سوريا اردوغان
يؤكد اصرار انقره على تامين حدودها
الجنوبيه بشكل كامل وقائد ما تعرفوا بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه يقول انه يتطلع للتنسيق
مع قوه النظام السوري للتصدي للعمليات
التركيه
اللهم صل الله
لقصف روسي مكثف القوه الانفصاليه في دونات
تقول انها توسع سيطرتها في الاقليم
والقوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد صدها عددا من
الهجمات
الرئيس الاوكراني بابتزاز الغرب بطرق عده
في اول تجمع منذ محاوله
عمران خان يقول انه سيناضل من اجل باكستان
حتى اخر قطره دم في حياته ويعلن استقاله
وادي حزبه كافا من البرلمانات الاقليميه
وسلطات تشدد الاجراءات الامنيه لمنع
الوصول انصاره الى العاصمه اسلام اباد
استنادا لما تعتبره تهديدا للامن القومي
الولايات المتحده تعلن وحضر معدات وخدمات
اتصالات من خمس شركات صينيه من بينها
هواوي وزي تي اي والهيئه الامريكيه
للاتصالات تقول انها تراجع التراخيص
الممنوحه سابقا
للمنتجات المحظوره
مشاهدينا في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد
على منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا قرار اداره
الرئيس الامريكي
حظر الموافقه على معدات اتصالات جديده من
شركتي هواوي تكنولوجيز وزتي الصينيتين
لانها تشكل خطرا غير مقبول على الامن
القومي الامريكي بحسب بيان لجنه الاتصالات
الفيدراليه
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم في اي سياق
ياتي القرار الامريكي بحظر معدات وخدمات
لشركه صينيه وقد جاءت اجابتكم على نحو
التاريخ
ما هو اربعين بالمئه قالوا انه ياتي في
سياق منافسه تجاريه بينما قال نحو 47% انه
سيجال ومناكفه سياسيه في حين صوت نحوه
13% بالقول ان القرار الامريكيه ياتي في
سياق اعتبارات تخص الامن القومي هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وانا نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انقر
لا تزال مصره على تامين خط الحدود بشكل
كامل وذاكره وسائل الاعلام مقربه مما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه ان الجيش التركيه
استهدف بالمدفعيه الثقيله محيطه
في حلب الشمالي وثلاث قرى تابعه لعين
العرب كوباني على الحدود السوريه التركيه
شماليه سوريا
من القوات التابعه للنظام السوري قتلوا
نتيجه التصعيد التركيه الاخيره الذي
استهدف نقاطا تتمركز فيها هذه القوات بريف
في حلب الشمالي
وقال يا قائد ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
ديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي ان حمايه شمال سوريا
من الهجمات التركيه هي وظيفه الجيش السوري
واكد مظلوم عبدي ان قوته تتطلع للتنسيق مع
قوات النظام السوري للتصدي للهجمات
التركيه واضاف عبده في تصريحات النقل
من امريكا وروسيا تعرضان الهجوم التركيه
لكن المواقف الدوليه يجب ان تكون اقوى مع
تصميم تركي على الهجوم وقال عبدي ان
الاداره الامريكيه ابلغته رسميا برفضيا
للعمليه
وبتواصلها مع انقره من اجله ايقافها على
حد قوله
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان عنصرين من
قواتها قتل يوم امس في منطقه العمليات
العسكريه في شمال العراق وبذلك يرتفع عدد
قتلى الجيش التركي خلال العمليات التي
يشنها على معاقل حزب العمال الخردستاني
الشماليه العراق الى ثلاثه
الدفاع التركيه الى ان قواتها حيدت سبعه
عناصر تابعه لحزب العمال للكره الصينيه في
شمال العراق
استنشاده ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
بقوات النظام السوري لدعمها في مواجهه
العمل العسكريه التركيه المحتمل يثير
اسئله عديده عن شكل العلاقه وتحالفات بين
تلك القوات والنظام السوري اضافه الى
اطراف اخرى حاضره ومؤثره في المشهد شمل
شرقي سوريا خصوصا وان تلك الاطراف تتفق في
تصنيف متقارب لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
مع استمرار الضربات التركيه على مناطق
وجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
يشير قائد تلك القوات الى ان حمايه
المنطقه هي وظيفه قوات النظام السوري وان
قواتهم تطلعوا الى التنسيق معها للتصدي
للهجمات التركيه تعيد هذا التصريحات الى
الواجهه الاسئله بشان الشكل العلاقه بينما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والنظام
السوري وحتى الولايات المتحده الداعم
الرئيسي لها بدايه فان المسلحين الاكراد
يتشاركون حاليا الوجود مع قوات النظام
السوري في مناطق عديده في الحسكه
والقامشلي وحلاوه الرفعه بنسبه نفوذ
وسيطره متفاوته من منطقه الى اخرى هذا
التقاسم مسببه في اوقات سابقه اشتباكات
بينهما في الحسكه والقامشلي بسبب تجاوز
احدهما التفاهمات بشان كيفيه اداره
المنطقه الرسمي للنظام السوري عبر تصريحات
لرئيسه بشار الاسد وضع المسلحين الاكراد
وغيرهم من المدعومين من واشنطن في خانه
العماله والخيانه ومع ذلك فقد ساندت قوات
النظام السوري ترى من مره ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وان لم يحدث هذا التدخل
فرقا كما حدث في عفرين خلال عمليه
العسكريه التركيه عام 2018
اقدم من ذلكم عن انطلاق الثوره السوريه
انسحبت قوات النظام السوري من مناطق في
شمال الشرقيه سوريا تركه اداره المنطقه
المسلحين الاكراد وتولى هؤلاء في بعض
الاحيان طبعا مظاهرات المناهضه للنظام
السوري والتي خرج فيها الاكراد والعرب
والسريان وكل مكونات المنطقه في المقابل
فانما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قاتلت
تنظيم الدوله بدعم من الولايات المتحده
لكن العمليات العسكريه التركيه السابقه
اشارت الى عدم رغبه واشنطن في دعم
المسلحين الاكراد في مواجهه الجيش التركي
وان كان الموقف الرسمي الامريكي ليعلن
صراحه رفضات تلك العمليه التي تهنى ان
واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي يشاركان تركيا
تصنيفها حزب العمال الكردستاني تنظيما
الارهابيا ومع ذلك فقد دعمت واشنطن وما
زالت تدعم المسلحين الاكراد في سوريا على
اختلاف مسمياتهم والمصنفين من تركيا على
انهم امتداد ونسخه سوريه من حزب العمال
الكردستاني
ينضم الينا من انقره
كتب والمحلله سياسي ومن ولايه اوكلاهما
البروفيسور جوش هولنداس مدير مركز الشرق
الاوسط بجامعه اوكلاهوما ساده معك دكتور
جورج هولنداس هل تتوقع ان تمنع الولايات
المتحده تركيا من عمليتها البريه تحديدا
في شمال سوريا
المناطق التي
ذكرت على انها قد تكون مستهدفه من قبل
عمليه تركيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قالت
بحزم ان هذا سوف يؤدي الى زعزعه الاستقرار
في المنطقه ويؤدي الى موجه جديده من
الوجوه وايضا الى الحق الضرر بالجهودي
للمكافحه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه لذلك ارى
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تخاطب
وتتحدث مع تركيا لا اعرف طبيعه المحادثه
طبعا تركيا او الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى
مساعده تركيا بالنسبه الى موضوع اوكرانيا
وبالتالي المحادثات حساسه
هل ستمضي تركيا في هذه العمليه
وتحولها الى عمليه بريه
رغم المعارضه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
تركيا
حزب العمال الكردستاني منذ اسبوعين قتل
سته اشخاص في قلبي اسطنبول واليوم مجددا
نحن نرى منظمه حزب العمال الكردستاني
الارهابيه وقوات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
الارهابيه تقتل الجنود الاتراك وبالتالي
هذه العمليه هي على الارجح ما سوف نراه في
الايام المقبله
طبعا تركيا الان ترد على هجمات حزب العمال
الكردستاني عاده نرى ضربات مدفعيه واهجمت
صاروخيه من قبل تركيا
لا نعرف بالضبط توقيت العمليه البريه ولكن
العمليه البريه تبدا عندما ترى تركيا ان
الظروف مواتعه اعتقد ان القيادات العسكريه
التركيه همم تنظر في الاوضاع الميدانيه
وعندما ترى القياده العسكريه ان الاوضاع
مواسيه لشني هذه العمليه البريه اعتقد ان
تركيا سوف تقوم بالفعل
بتنفيذي هذه العمليه البريه التي تخضع في
المنطقه التي
لم تجبني بالفعل عن السؤال يعني كيف
ستتعامل انقره مع هذا الرفض الامريكي
المعلن
كويس كويس
طرح على الرئيس التركي
لم يتبدل ولم يتغير ان تركيا لا تتفاوض
بشانها امنها القومي مع اي دوله اخرى وفقا
لميثاق الامم المتحده يحق لتركيا ان ترد
ويحق لتركيا ان تؤمن حدودها وبالتالي لا
ارى ان تركيا تتفاوض لا مع روسيا ولا مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بنسبه الى
امنها القومي المساله تطرح على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا ما هاجمت تنظيمات
ارهابيه
الحنيف التركي طبعا الحليب في حلف شمال
الاطلسي وماذا كانت الولايات المتحده تدعم
التنظمات الارهابيه السؤال الى تركيا بل
يجب ان تفكر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بنتيجه هذه الامور
والحتى اللحظه الراهنه استمعنا من
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض البيت الابيض
يرى او يفهم ان لتركيا اسباب شرعيه ودوافع
شرعيه لاستهداف في حزب العمال الكردستاني
في الداخل السوري ولكن المهم بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده ليس حزب العمال او قوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه بل النفط الولايات
المتحده
في سوريا تركيا
وايضا مكافحه تنظيم داعش
طبعا تعرفون ان تركيا تنخرط في قتال ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه اكثر من اي دوله
اخرى
هذه الفكره بالتحديد سيد جوشوا ماذا لو
قدمت انقره هذه الضمانات
للولايات المتحده تامين المنطقه النفطيه
اييه تامين واستمرار العمل بقتال تنظيم
الدوله هل سترفع او يعني ستلغي الولايات
المتحده هذا الرفض وتسمح
بعمليه عسكريه تركيه في شمال سوريا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في الحقيقه
تركيا يوم الاحد ضرب 89 هدفا مختلفه في
شمال سوريا والعراق بعد مقتل 31 شخص
واصابه عدد كبير من الناس هذا الرد
الاساسيه التي حصل
طبعا
ادى الى الحافه
بقوات حمايه الشعب الكرديه وبحزب العمال
الكردستاني اكثر من الضرر الذي لحق بتركيا
في المقام الاول والولايات المتحده اعتقد
انها سوف تبذل قصار جهدها لاقناع تركيا
بان العمليه البريه لن تؤدي الى حل
المشكلات بل الى تاجيل المشكلات في سوريا
والقتال ضد تنظيم الدوله والحق الضرر ايضا
بالعلاقات حيث ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت
هلا مع تركيا بسبب النزاع في اوكرانيا
نتحدث عن حوالي
200 قصف تركي في العراق لا نتحدث عن سوريا
حيث وجرت عمليات او قصف اكثر بكثير همم
وهذا الامر يستمر والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لم تبذل الكثير لحمايه الاكراد
في سوريا وفي ايران والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنتقد بشكل كبير من قبل الاكراد
باختصار باختصار شديد عفوا
لم يعد لدينا الكثير من الوقت ماذا لو مضى
تركيا بعمليتها العسكريه رغم معارضه
الولايات المتحده التي تحتاجها في الكثير
من الملفات باختصار ارجوك
عايز
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تعبر عن
الكثير من المواقف اعتقدوا انها تحاول ان
تجري
المفاوضات بشكل هادئ لا تود ان تؤدي الى
الحاق الضرر بالعلاقات مع عن قرار تركيا
الى شريك مهم الولايات المتحده بشكل كبير
في الشرق الاوسط واوكرانيا وروسيا اذا
تركيا لديها اوراق متعدده وهذا لا شكا
كثير والولايات المتحده تودوا ان تستمر في
علاقاتها مع تركيا بشكل جيد ولكن في الوقت
نفسه تود ان تحميه الحلفاء الاكراد
شكرا لك جوش ولاندس مدير مركز الشرق
الاوسط بجامعه اوكلاهما وشكرا اوزيان تكيت
الكاتب والمحل السياسي التركي كان من
انقره
[موسيقى]
في تطورات يا حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
كثافه القوات الروسيه وقصفها على مواقع
اوكرانيا
خشيه من تكرار سيناريو خرسان ومن قبله
خاكيز يواصل الجيش الروسي والقوات
الانفصاليه المواليه له التركيز على
جبهاتهم مقاطعه في دنيا شرقيه اوكرانيا في
ظل المكاسب الميدانيه التي نجحها في
تحقيقها الايام الماضيه ف فضلا عن تمكنهما
من انتزاع المناطق كانت تحت سيطره الجيش
الاوكراني لا سيما في محيط المحوري
كوبيانز شمال غربيه
فانهما نجح ايضا في صد محاولات الجيش
الاوكراني باستعاده مواقعك كان قد خسرها
جنوبي المقاطعه في المقابل يؤكد الجيش
الاوكراني انه صدم محاولات تقدم للجيش
الروسي في دوم بس رغم ان تلك المحاولات
رافقها قصف مدفعي وصاروخي طال كرامات
وعددا من المناطق التي لا تزال تحت سيطرتك
في دنيا ايه في مقاطعه جنوب شرقي البلاد
اتهمت السلطات الاوكرانيات الجيش الرو
بمواصله سياسه قصف البنى التحتيه الحيويه
داخل ما تسميه الجزء المحرر من زبرجيا في
حين يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني انه نجح في
تدمير مستودعات ذخيره وايقاع عدد من
الاصابات في صفوف القوات الروسيه بعد قصف
شانه على مدينه مليت بول التي تعتبرها
موسكو العاصمه المؤقته لزابولوجيا سيناريو
القصف الروسي المكثف تركز ايضا على الجزء
الخاضع للسيطره الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
خرسان اذ تقول سلطاتك ان عددا من المدنيين
سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح بسبب القصف المتواصل
على مركز المقاطعه وبانها بدات باجلاء
المرضى من مستشفيات خرسون الى مناطق اكثر
امنا بل انها نصحت المدنيين بمغادره
المدينه بسبب الضرر البالغ الذي تعرضت له
البنيه التحتيه هناك وعجز السلطات عن
توفير الخدمات الاساسيه لهم مسلسل الق
روسيه قال كذلك مناطق خارج الاقاليم
الاربعه التي ضمتها موسكو اليها اذ تقول
شرطه ديني بروت ثالث كبرى مدن اوكرانيا ان
عددا من الجرحى سقطوا نتيجه قصف صاروخيه
استهدف احد احياء المدينه وان رجال
الانقاذ يعملون على رفع الانقاض والبحث عن
عدد من المفقودين في الحي السكني المستهدف
[موسيقى]
وتزداد المعارك شراسه في جبهه القتال
باقليم دومباز ويستمر القصف الروسي على
مدن وبلدات الاقليم بينما ترسل روسيا
تعزيزات الى المنطقه من القوات المسحبه من
مقاطعه خلصن جنوبيه اوكرانيا
الجيش الاوكراني استعداده التام للمواجهه
نعم مازلت على قيد الحياه حمانا الله هذه
المره من امام بيته المقصود في ضواحي
كراماتوست هذا مكان يوري يخبر به عائلته
التي كان قد نقلها بعيدا وبقي هو هنا قدر
للصاروخ ان يسقط امام منزله فنجى وهذا جزء
من يوميات العديد من مدن مقاطعه دونيت
وبلداتها مع القصف الروسي لكن النتيجه
تعادتا لا تكون متشابهه
مدنيه بالكامل ولما تخيل ان تصادف لاننا
لسنا على الجبهه اما الذي يجعل مني هدفه
اصطحابنا الجيش الاوكراني الى احدى نقاط
المواجهه على جبهه دونيت وكلما اقتربنا
اتضحت اثار المعارك العنيفه التي دارت هنا
عندما وصلنا كانت وحده المدفعيه التي
يقودها دي مترو تستعد لتوجيه ضربه لتجمعات
الجيش الروسي بعد ان وصلت احداثيات المكان
قال لنا ان الاسلحه الغربيه الحديثه
ساعدتهم على الصمود رغم شراسه المعارك
طوال هذه المده في وجه الجيش الذي يوصف
بانه ثاني اقوى جيوش العالم
يمكننا الانتقال بين المواقع بشكل اسرع
والاصابه بدقه اكثر قبل ذلك كنا مجموعات
اكبر وبطيئه الحركه لذلك كنا هدفا اسهل
لكن ما زال لدينا القليل مقارنه بالعتاد
الروسي
المعارك مستمره على طول خطوط لمواجهه في
اقليم دومباز الا ان محورين بخموت
وافديفكا في دونات ومحور اكريمي نصبتوفا
في لوغانسك تبقى هي الاسخن وهي المحاور
التي ترجح قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
تعذزها روسيا بقوات المظليين الخاصه
المنسحبه من مقاطعه خرسون في الجنوب
وهو في الخمسين من عمره يبدو ان هذا
التطور على خطورته لا يعني له الكثير
روسيا هي من قررت انضمام للجيش عندما دمرت
منطقه نعم وصلتنا اخبار تعزيزاتهم بالنسبه
الينا ما دمنا نملك ذخائر في مدفعنا
فسستمر في القتال حتى النهايه
مع توتر الاخبار عن تعزيزات الروسيه كبيره
قادمه من الجبهه الجنوبيه
سياسيه اجرى الرئيس الوزراء البلجيكيه
الكسندر دي كروز في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
تيف مشاورات مع الرئيس فولو دو ميرسي وقال
زيننسكي في مؤتمر صحفي انه طلب دعما
عسكريا دوليا اكبر لبلاده
وقد كانت من السباقين الى تجميد 50 مليون
يورو من الاصول الروسيه ان لم يكن اكثر
وهذا مهم للغايه لاجبار روسيا على تعويض
الخسائر التي تسببت بها شهيدنا هجمات
صاروخيه ارهابيه ونحن بحاجه الى مزيد من
الدعم وبلجيكا مستعده لدعم اوكرانيا
بمولدات الطاقه وهذا مهم جدا لصالح
المجتمعنا
في المقابل القناه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه مارياسه خروفا ان الرئيس
الاوكراني فولدومر زيلينسكي دخلها فلكه
الخاص وبدا الان في ابتزاز الغرب بعده طرق
واوضحت زخرفه في تصريح لقناه روسيه ان دول
الغرب تفهم الناس اللينسكي خارج عن
سيطرتها الكامله وانه دخل بالفعل في مدار
غير قابل للتحكم فيه واشارت زخرفه الا انه
اوكرانيا تحتاج الان الى المزيد والمزيد
من الاموال والاسلحه الغربيه على نطاق
كونيه بسبب صعوبات التي يواجهها الغرب
معنى من موسكو فيكتور لتبكين العقيده
الاحتياطي في الجيش الروسيه والخبير
العسكري سيد فيكتور
الان اذا اردنا ان نتحدث على عن محور
تلك المشتعله في الجبهه الشرقيه
ما الهدف الروسي التالي في تلك المنطقه
خصوصا مع تقدم فصل الشتاء وصعوبات التي
يفرضها على ارض المعركه
العسكريه
من القوات الاوكرانيه هذه الجمهوريه الجزء
من روسيا ولا يجب ان يكون في الاراضي
الروسيه اي قوات عدوه وهذا الهدف الذي
سيستمر في العمليات العسكريه
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
العسكريه
والدبابات والسيارات
المدرعه الدبابات
نيبريستال
اي عقبات بنسبه لنا على عكس المعدات
الموجوده في اوكرانيا التي تسير على
العجلات وبالنسبه لهاء الحركه ستكون اصعب
ولكن اذا استددنا الى حتى تصريحات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عندما تتحدث عن صد هجمات
اوكرانيه لاستعاده مناطق سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه او المولون لها تبدو وكان
القوات الاوكرانيه هي صاحبه المبادره في
الهجوم في حين ان القوات الروسيه في موقع
دفاع في هذه الجبهه
نويت
شيء طبيعي في المعارك احدهم يدافع والاخر
يهاجم ولكن القوه الروسيه تنتظر
التعبئه والمد بالجنود المدربين الذين
يتدربون الان القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر عددا
في تلك الجبهات من القوات الروسيه لذلك
نحن نقوم
عمليات دفاعيه وهجوميه احيانا ولكن عندما
يصل الجنود سوف نقوم بها جمال اكثر فعاليه
عمليا ماذا استفاد الجيش الروسي من
الانسحاب من خير صون في حين انه يستهدفها
بالقصف بشكل همم شبه يوميا
نحن خرجنا
موجوده على موقع متدني تحت النبرو
هي معرضه لخطر الغرق اذا دمرت سد كخوفتك
والسكان والمدنيين والجيش ايضا الذين
كانوا متواجدين هناك ممكن ان يتضررون بشكل
كبير جدا والان خرجنا من هناك ونحن على
الضفه المرتفعه من
النهر اما اخر سن فهي في الضفه المتدنيه
ونحن نستطيع ان نكشف تلك المنطقه ومن
السهل ان نقص في تلك المناطق من من
المناطق المرتفعه لذلك اوكرانيا الان تخرج
قواتها من خرطون وحتى المدنيين اما الذين
لا يريدون الخروج من خرفان يقوم باعدامهم
فورا لقد اعد مميزيد من 100 شخص من
الخبير العسكري والعقيده احتياط في الجيش
الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك
سكرتير لجنه الدفاع والامن القومي
والاستخبارات في البرلمان
الاوكرانيه
سيدروسان هل استمعت الى ضيفنا من موسكو
بشان ما تقوم به القوات
الاوكرانيه في خيرسون حاليا
مرضه
اريد ان اقول ان الشخص الذي يوضح هذا
الاسباب
لانسحابهم من خلصنا ان احد الضفه اعلى من
اخرى وان هذا سبب حقيقي في الواقع عندنا
كرتون في الجانب الايمن هي اعلى من الجانب
الايسر حيث الروس الان
اعتقد انه لا يعلم حتى الظروف الجغرافيه
همم والتكتيكيه هناك اما قولها ان ال قوات
الاوكرانيه تعدم وتقتل المواطنين هناك
نحن نرى الكثير من الفيديوهات التي تظهر
كيف يستقبل المواطنين في خرفان الجيش
الاوكراني نحن حررناهم
والسكان يعود الى الحياه الطبيعيه الى
الان لم يكن لديهم اي اتصالات او كهرباء
او مساعدات طبيه لان نحن نعيد هذا الى
المدينه وهذا الحديث عن ان روسيا سوف
تهاجم هاجمونا اذا كنتم تستطيعوا لاننا
نرى خمسه مرات انسحب بها القوات الروسيه
من كيف ثم من صومي
وشرليها افضل
وينتظرون الامدادات
حسنا نحن ايضا ننتظر هذه الامدادات ولكن
همم قد يكون الوضع في اقليم بس مختلفا ااه
شيئا ما همم خصوصا وان ضيفنا ايضا تحدث عن
امدادات ستاتي وهمم بالتالي سيكون الوضع
هناك مختلف عن باقي المناطق التي انسحبت
منها القوه الروسيه
اردنيه
[موسيقى]
ان الحرب سهله للجيش الاوكراني نحن نفهم
ان الروس سوف يحاولوا ان يحتل جميع مناطق
دانيسك لانهم لا لم ينتصروا في اي من
المواقع كانوا يعتقدوا انهم سوف ينتصروا
بثلاث ايام على اوكرانيا
ولكن في الوقت
يقوموا بمد القوه الروسيه
كان لدينا اعداد اكبر بكثير من اعداد
الرؤوس نحن نزيد هذه الاعداد سوف نحرر
خرصان كامله
المعركه الحاسمه نحن نحارب لاجل تحرير
اراضينا وهذا يشبه ااا
المعارك الوحشيه التي كانت في العصور
الوسطى همم حي حيث يقوم الروث باجبار
المواطنين رز بالموت لاجل المعاركهم نحن
نقوم بتحرير اراضينا في جرنكف وخرصون وكما
حررنا جزيره الافعى نحرر مختلف المناطق
هذه ارضنا وهذه وطننا نعلم ان هذا ليس سهل
ولكن الروس سوف
نقضيهم ونحاكمهم عسكريا شكرا
لجنه الدفاع والامن القوميه
والاستخبارات في البرنامج الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
سوق قاتل من اجل هذا البلد حتى اخر قطره
دمني هذا ما قاله رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان لعشرات
الالاف من انصاره في اول خطاب عام اليوم
السبت منذ اطلاق النار عليه في محاوله
اغتيال في وقت صادق من الشهر الجاري واعلن
عمران خان في خطابه استقالته كل نواه
بحزبه من البرلمانات الاقليميه في خطوه
يترتب عليها عند دخولها حيز التنفيذ حل
الحكومتين المحليتين في اقليميه خيبر
والبنجر
مسيره احتجاجيه هي الاطول في تاريخ
باكستان قطع خلالها المشاركون 300 كيلو
متر على مدى 30 يوما وتعرض خلالها قائدهم
لمحاوله اغتيال فاشله
حزب انصاف زعامه الرئيس الحكومه المقالي
من منصبه عمران خان وقبل ان يصل بمسيره
حزبه الاحتجاجيه الى نهايتها فاجيء الجمعه
واحدث مزيدا من الارباك السياسي في
باكستان ناقش نظام كاهيستاني لينا انسحابه
من كل البرلمانات المحليه في الاقاليم
وسنعقد لاحقا اجتماعا لتحديد موعد استقاله
وبناء من تلك البرلمانات اذ لا نريد ان
نكون جزءا من النظام الحالي الفاسد قد
يتسبب خروج وبحزب انصاف من البرلمانات
الاقليميه في نوع من الفراغ السياسي
تحديدا في اقليمين تحت حكم الحزب غير ان
الدستور يمنح الحكومه الفيدراليه في اسلام
اباد سلطه اداره الاقليمين بشكل مباشر
حكومه باكستان رفضت تحديدا موعد انتخابات
مبكرا واغلقت بحجج امنيه منافذه عده تربط
العاصمه بموقع تجمهر مؤيدي حزب
انصافريه عن بعض التهديدات الامنيه وقد
اتخذنا كل التدابير الاحترازيه ونشرنا
قرابه 70,000 رجل
من مداخلها
وزير الداخليه شروط عديده لامكانيه
التواصل مع حزب انصاف
على عمران
حزبه الى البرلمان ليمارس السياسه
وليتواصلوا مع الاتلاف الحاكم ويمكن لقاء
ان يختار من بين قاده الاحزاب الحاكمه من
يبدا التواصل معه لاطلاق عمليه سياسيه
واسعه وبعد ذلك يمكن ان نتفق معه لتحديدي
موعد الانتخابات
استقطاب سياسي حاد تمر به باكستان كان
رئيس الجمهوريه اول من تحدث عنه محذرا من
نتائجها السلبيه والتي ربما بدات بالظهور
مع ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى ثلاثين في
المئه بحسب الحكومه
عبد الرحمن مطار الجزيره اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
في خطوه هي الاحداث بحمله تشنها واشنطن
على شركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه العملاقه
حضرت اداره الرئيس الامريكي
اتصالات جديده من شركهيه هواوي تكنولوجيا
وزتي ايه الصينيتين لانها تشكل خطرا غير
مقبولا على الامن القومي الامريكي الخطوه
تاتي وصل مخاوف في الاوساط الامريكيه من
ان تستخدمنا شركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه
للتجسس على الامريكي
الحرب التجاريه هي اذا المستمره بين
واشنطن وبيجين وربما بحده اكبر الان في
ساحه التكنولوجيا
بقرار من السلطات الامريكيه بات محظورا
استيراد المعدات وخدمات الاتصالات التي
تقدمها خمس شركات صينيه بينها هواوي
لقواعد مماثله وكذلك شركتان
اللاتيني تقدمان معدات مراقبه بالفيديو
والتكنولوجيا الرقميه اضافه الى شركه هتلر
المتخصصه في معدات الراديو والاتصالات
تشير الهيئه الامريكيه لتنظيم الاتصالات
الى ان تلك الشركات تشكل تهديدا غير مقبول
للامن القومي للولايات المتحده
لكنها لا تضع الخطوه في سياقها ليست تنافس
بجديد ولا هي سياسه الاجراءات العقابيه
الذي اتبعتها اداره دونالد ترامب السابقه
فقد حضرت عام 2019 معدات هواوي وخدماتها
وقطعتها عن نظام اندرويد التابعي لجوجل
لكن دون ان يصل القرار الى حد الحظر التام
في الولايات المتحده والان تبدو اداره
الرئيس الديمقراطي
كانما تكمل حرب سلفه التجاريه على الصين
بل تراها تتخذ موقفا حازما تجاه مصنعين
معدات الاتصالات الصينيين ممن تشتبه في
انهم يتجسسون لصالح سلطان
للدواعي الامنيه عينها منعت اخيرا تدفق
تكنولوجيا الرقائق الالكترونيه عاليه
التقنيه الى الاسواق الصينيه
فحرمتها بذلك من مكون مهم لشبكات اتصالات
الجيل الخامس ثم تاتي الحمله الاحداث على
شركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه العملاقه لتول
هيبا اكثر الحرب التجاريه بين اكبر
اقتصادين في العالم
التعريفات الجمركيه وتايوان والملكيه
الفكريه والامن السيبراني وغيرها من
القضايا الخلافيه ابدت قيمته جوبادل على
هامشي قمه العشرين الاخيره الرغبه في
تفادي تحولها الى ساعه
واشنطن تتحدى محاوله التقارب تلك بمواصله
ما تدعوه تاسيس قضايا التكنولوجيا
والتجاره
اما الامريكيون سيشهرون مبررات تحركها
الهواجس الامنيه في المقام الاول وبين
الموقفين يقف خبراء ممن يقلقهم الصراع
التقني قد يكون محددا حاسما لنفوذ السياسي
والاقتصادي والعسكري لكنه في نظرهم لن يمر
بدون خسائر كبيره للطرفين وللعالم باكمله
المحاضر في امن المعلومات في جامعه سوريه
سيد نيشان هي حرب تجاريه بين الصين او بين
الولايات المتحده والصين ام مساله امن
قومي فعلي للولايات المتحده
نجيبه عن هذا السؤال حول ما يحصل الان حيث
ان التفاصيل صحيحه ولكن هناك احتمال بان
الحكومه الصينيه قد اثرت على هذه الشركات
لكي تضع برمجيات في الهواتف على سبيل
المثال او في الشبكات هناك في السابق
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تم منع
استخدام المعدات وخصوصا التي تاتي من شركه
هواوي والان الامر يحصل بنسبه الى هذا
النوع من الاجهزه لا نعرف اذا ما كان
الامر مرتبط بمجال الاعمال او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ودول الغربيه ان تعزل
الصين في قطاع
التقنيه او اما اذا كانت تشكل تهديدا للام
القومي لطالما كان يعتبر هذا الامر
اعترافا امريكيا غير مباشر بتفوق الصين في
مجال همم تكنولوجيا لاتصالات والجيل
الخامس
بحد ذاته ما رايك
في الصين هناك شركات مشابهه في الغرب هناك
منافسه في هذا المجال ولكن صحيح ايضا ان
الحكومه الصينيه لديها حصه في هواوي وفي
زي تي اي وشركه اخرى وهذا يؤثر على القرار
الامريكي خصوصا اذا ما اخذنا على الاعتبار
التاثير الذي تحضى به الحكومه الصينيه على
قرارات هذه الشركات هذا هو الجزء الاساسي
اذا كان الامر كذلك همم تحدثنا سيد نيشان
هل يمكن ان نتوقع مزيدا من القرارات
المماثله من الولايات المتحده تحت عنوان
الامن القومي الامريكي
يا امين شكلي لوك سلايم
يبدو الامر كذلك هائل هذا هو الاتجاه الذي
تذهب به معظم الحكومات الغربيه
الحد من تاثير الشركات الصينيه في الماضي
تم تغيير المعدات على مستوى الشركات
المشغله للشبكات
يمكننا ان نتوقع المزيد من الاجراءات هناك
شركه تيك توك والتي ذكرت في السابق ومقرها
الصين هي تحظى شعبيه كبيره في الغرب
وبالتالي يتعين علينا ان ننتظر ما اذا
كانت هذه القرارات سوف تنتقل من المعدات
الى البرمجيات كذالك شكرا جزيلا لك
في امن المعلومات في جامعه سيري حدثتنا من
لندن
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعوذ بكم الان الى الازمه
الباكستانيه ومحطاتها وخطوره المرحله
الراهنه في المشهد السياسي والسؤال بدايه
كيف تبدو خريطه مسيره مؤيد رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان
نظم التجمع الاحتجاجيه لانصار خان على ارض
المفتوحه شاسعه بين العاصمه الباكستانيه
المجاوره المدينه التي تضم مقر قياده
الجيش النافذ في البلاد
وعلى مدار الاشهر الماضيه نظم خان سلسله
من التجمعات الجماهيريه في كل انحاء
البلاد وخلال ساعات الماضيه كانت
التوقعاته ان يكون تجمع السبت
الاكبر حتى الان دفع ذلك
من افراد الامن واغلاق طرق بحاويته
فقد اغلقت من قبل السلطات الباكستانيه
اغلقت العاصمه اسلام اباد بثلاثه مداخل
رئيسيه من اصل خمسه تربطها بمدينه روى
البندي المجاوره لها وتابعه اداريا باقليم
البنجاب وذلك تحسبا لاي اضربات فيما امرت
السلطات المحليه لنشر 20,000 من رجال
الشرطه وجنود قوه الدرك وعناصر ميليشيا
شبه عسكريه تابعه للحكومه الفيدراليه وذلك
لتوفير حمايه للعصمه
والمنشاتها ومبانيها الرئيس
وكانت قوافل من انصار الحزب تتدفق من كل
انحاء باكستان مع حافلات
وشاحنات وسيارات
وسيارات تحمل اعلام الحركه وسؤاله كيف
وصلت باكستان الى هذه الدرجه من التاذب
دخل الصراع السياسي في بستان مرحله اكثر
توتر في نيسان ابريل الماضي عندما اطيح
برئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان في تصويت
لحجب الثقه عن البرلمان
انهاء حكم خان لم يكن مثل الصديقيه حيث
يعد عمران خان اول رئيس وزراء في تاريخ
باكستاني يعزل من منصبه بحجم الثقه ماذا
حدث في عقاب هذا الاجراء غير المسبوق في
باكستان
تحولت الاحتجاجات التي قادها خان في ايار
مايو الى 24 ساعه من التوتر والاضطرابات
مع حصار العاصمه واشتباكه في كل انحاء
باكستان بين الشرطه
ومتظاهرين وفي ثالث من تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر تعرض موكب خان لهجوم اصيب خلاله
رئيس الوزراء السابق في ساقيه واليوم هو
اول ظهور علني له منذ اطلاق النار عليه
وتعتبر مسيره السبت ذروه ما تسمى بالمسيره
الطويله لحزب خان حركه الانصاف
الباكستانيه وذلك من اجل الضغط على
الحكومه لكن ما هو الهدف الهدف الرئيس
لهذه الاحتجاجات
حزب انصاف يحشد
المناصرين لتجري انتخابات مبكرا بينما
الحكومه الباكستانيه تريد الاستمرار حتى
موعد الانتخابات في اكتوبر 2023
لتاخذ فرصه
لاصلاح الاقتصاد
ماما الينا من روما الدكتور دييجو ميرانو
الاستاذ في جامعه نابولي لورينتال والباحث
في معهد دراسات جنوب اسيا بجامع سنغافوره
الوطنيه دكتور مرحبا بك
وانطلاقا من هذه
الشرح الذي قدمناه الى اين يمكن ان تصل
الازمه الباكستانيه في ضوء التجاذب الحاصل
بين عمران خان وانصاره من جهه والحكومه من
جهه الثانيه
والايكساوي الحقيقي
عن هذا السؤال بنسبه الى الوضع الداخليه
الباكستاني هو
معقد للغايه
وملتمس للغايه في هذه المرحله بالمقارنه
مع ما كان عليه هو اصلا التعقيد الذي كان
قائما بنسبه الى موضوع تعيين
قائد
القوات المسلحه هذا انتصارا للحكومه حيث
انه ياتي بعد
سلفه الذي لعب دورا اساسيا في الاطاحه
بعمران خان من ناحيه اخرى
عمران خان لديه ارتفاع في منسوب شعبيته
وشعبيه حزبه بعد محاوله الاغتيال التي
تعرض لها لذلك يحاول ان يضغط باتجاه
الانتخابات مبكرا لكي يستفيدها من هذه
الموجه العاربه من الدعم اذن الوضعه غير
واضح الان ولكن يبدو ان ما يستمر في
باكستان وهو سلطه او قوه
المؤسسه العسكريه هذه المؤسسه هي القويه
في باكستان
المؤسسه العسكريه الان همم برايك في اي
اتجاه يمكن ان تكون في ضوء استعراض همم
العضلات الشعبي اذا صح التعبير الذي يقوم
به حزب الانصاف وهو عمران خان
ولا فينك دمياط
الجيش هو في موقف غريب حيث انه من جهه لا
يودوا الجيش ان يدخل بشكل مباشر في العملي
السياسي وعمران خان اتهم الحكومه
الضباط كبار في محاولته الاغتيال وهذا ادى
من الجانب الاخر الى نفي هذا الاتهام
وطبعا في امكانيات الانخراط في العمل
السياسيه المباشر الجيش لا يحدد ذلك الجيش
يحبب ان يكون مؤسسه فوق
المجال السياسي من جانب اخر الحكومه لعبه
دورا اساسيا بتعيين الجنرال المدير
لقياده القوات المسلحه الباكستانيه
وبالتالي يمكن ان تتوقع الحكومه ان يكون
ممتنا لها ولكن في الوقت نفسه لا تتوقع
الولاء الكامل من الجيش لذلك الجيش في
الاشهر المقبله سوف يحاول اللا يناصر
الحكومه بشكل كامل بشكل علني ولكن بكليه
تاكيد لن يدعم عوده عمران خان الى السلطه
المره الاخيره في العام 2018 الجيش ادى
دورا اساسيا لكي يتاكد من ان يربح حزب
انصاف ولكن في هذه المره عمران خان هو
لوحده
لماذا الجيش لا يريد لعمران خان ان يعود
الى السلطه ولو عبر انتخابات كما يطالب
بانتخابات مبكرا كما يطالب حزب انصاف
ير
[موسيقى]
اولا على مستوى
شخصيه القائد الجديد للجيش ثم اقالته في
العام
2021 من قبل عمران خالد من منصبه في
الاستخبارات الباكستانيه وبالتالي هناك
خصومه شخصيه في هذا المجال وايضا عمران
خان حاول بكل السبل ان يتفادا ان يصبح
جنرال منير
قائد الجديد للقوات المسلحه الباكستانيه
وهذا الصراع
الشخصي سوف يلعب دورا اساسيا ومحوري هنا
وايضا هناك مساله اخرى تدفع القوات
المسلحه او هناك مسائل اخرى تدفع نقاط
المسلحه الى
رفشه شكرا
[موسيقى]
والباحث في مع الدراسات جنوب اسيا بجامعه
سنغافوره الوطنيه حدثتنا من روما
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا موعد
استعراض اهم الانباء عبر العالم قبل
الانتقال الى ساعه من الرياضه في يوميات
المونديال
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انقره
ما زالت مصره على تامين خط الحدود بشكل
كامل وذكرت وسائل اعلام مقربه مما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان الجيش التركي
مدفعيا على محيط مدينه تل رفعه 30 قرن
تابعه لعين العرب كوباني شماليه سوريا
قال قائد ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
مظلوم عبد ان حمايه شمال سوريا من الهجمات
التركيه هي وظيفه الجيش السوري واكد مظلوم
عبدي ان قوته تتطلعوا للتنسيق مع قوات
النظام السوري للتصدي للهجمات التركيه
قالت القوه الاوكرانيه ان القوه الروسيه
جنه قصفا مكثفا على رخيصه ودينيبرو
وزابولوجيا وفي دنياك قالت السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا ان الجيش الروسيه
والقوات الحديثه يواصلان استعاده مناطق
وذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت ثمانيه محاولات روسيه للتقدم في
المقاطعه
اجرى رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي مشاورات مع
الرئيس الاوكراني
انه يقدر الدعم البلجيكي وكشف انه طلب
دعما عسكريا دوليا اكبر خصوصا في مجال
نزال الغام
قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه ان الرئيس الاوكراني داخل
فلكه الخاص وبدا الان في ابتزاز الغرب
بطرق عده واوضحت زخرفه ان دول الغرب تفهم
الناس لينسكي خارج عن سيطرتها الكامله
وانه دخل بالفعل في مدار غير قابل للتحكم
فيه على حد تعبيره
قال عمران خان زعيم وحزب انصاف انه سيناضل
من اجل باكستان حتى اخر قطره دم في حياته
وفي اول تجمع شعبي احضره منذ محاولات
اغتياله اعلنخان استقاله وبحز به من
برلماني اقليمي خيبر والبنجر ما يترتب
عليه حل حكومتي الاقليمين
واشددت السلطه الاجراءات الامنيه لمنع
الوصول انصار عمران خان الى العاصمه اسلام
اباد
حضرت السلطات الامريكيه استيراد معدات
اتصالات جديده من شركه هواوي تكنولوجيا
وزد تي اي الصينيتين وبرد لجنه الاتصالات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه قرارها بان الشركتين
تمثلان خطرا غير مقبولا على الامن القومي
الامريكي
مشاهدينا نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]